we just were able to accomplish
something i've hoped we could accomplish
for years
which is to expand the replay system
we're trying to address the two fouls
that that most impact gains so forget
the end of our game we had data that
said these are the most impactful plays
and that's what replay was designed for
historically as we all know we've pushed
back to us to expand it and uh but at
the same time you can't put your head in
the sand so we definitely uh
we were able to make sausage in one day
which is good for us
various voices and faces related to the
expansion of replay for the purposes of
offensive defense pass interference and
rich mckay who i respect i admire and i
appreciate what he's done for the league
but one of the reasons they had to make
sausage in one day chris guys like rich
mckay were resisting making sausage
until they realized they had no choice
but to make sausage if they had planned
for this a little bit better then quite
possibly
we wouldn't have to address the points
we're going to be addressing soon
because we'd already have answers to it
it feels like it was slapped together so
quickly a couple of nuances may have
gotten overlooked yeah yeah maybe
certainly i mean again it's going to be
you know trial by era i i don't think
that's really going to be error i should
say uh i think that's going to be the
thing we're going to kind of see this as
the year plays out whether it's fair or
not hey the first thing that i thought
about mike when i when i saw this
and i i think you're kind of close on
this or it's on your radar as well is
pick plays right i thought actually that
could be a good good reason that this is
the this replay uh the new the new way
about it is there because i do wonder
about you know hey pig play has become
such a big part of the nfl it's cheap
yardage for the offensive side of the
ball so many teams kind of cheat the
rules that's supposed to happen within
one yard of the line of scrimmage when i
sit there and watch film a lot of them
happen at two three yards down down the
field so i think that's one thing that
could favor the defense a little bit
which i like because the defense is
already the disadvantage at this day and
age in the nfl uh so that was the first
thing that jumped out to me because let
me just jump in to make sure
interference can happen before the ball
is thrown yes offensively defensively it
can't defensively pass interference
happens when the ball is in the air so
for replay review of defensive pass
interference the ball's got to be in the
air for offensive and they didn't
specify and they didn't limit they
didn't restrict they just said offensive
pass interference right it can happen as
written in the rule book before the ball
is thrown if you have blocking more than
one yard downfield within a yard it's
not offensive pass interference beyond a
yard it becomes a pick play and the way
it's set up chris yeah let me give you
the example sure touchdown scored by the
offense on a pass right okay and no push
off by the receiver in the end zone
before he catches the ball so no
offensive pass interference well hang on
a second we got to spin it back and see
whether or not there was blocking more
than one yard down the field
before that ball was thrown and if there
was and if there's indisputable visual
evidence clear and obvious evidence
whatever standard we want to apply 50
drunks in a bar would all say that guy
was blocking the other guy more than a
yard down the field that's offensive
pass interference that's going to wipe
the touchdown off the board even if it
wasn't seen in real time yeah no doubt
about it i like that aspect of it now i
don't want to get ticky tacky there
though with like okay it's supposed to
happen within one yard of the line and
one yard of the line of scrimmage if
it's a touchdown it was you know a yard
and a half down the field i i hope
that's not going to be overturned yeah
go here's the key though that's where we
get back to the standard that applies to
replay revenue what is al river on the
senior vp of officiating going to do
when it's time to review past
interference whether it is a potential
pick play whether it is an uncatchable
or catchable ball which is part of this
there was no no language in this new
rule that says it only applies to
whether or not there was contact with
the receiver or contact by the receiver
before the ball's thrown while the
ball's in the air with the case may be
it catchable or uncatchable one of them
we always see the hand over the head
yeah that's one of the big arguments
it's not catchable that's got to be part
of this replay review now is there
overwhelming evidence it was catchable
is there overwhelming evidence it wasn't
catchable that's going to be another
aspect of of the the balancing act how
riveron has to do and i'll tell you what
chris i said this earlier on the radio
side if i'm out river on first order of
business today i'm going in i'm plopping
my ass in the commissioner's desk a
chair or on his desk and saying give me
a raise i want to raise because my job
just got a hell of a lot harder yeah
that's a that's a solid point mike i
agree because there's going to be a lot
for him to look at you know and again
you're right it's just going to be uh
it's going to be a very fine line i also
think of instances like hey it's it's
jalen ramsey and odell beckham jr
running down the field okay and there's
no pass interference called okay but you
know hey the coach goes man it looked
like there was a lot of hand fighting
and and jalen ramsey might have pushed
odell beckham jr you know just kind of
as the ball was getting there but
earlier in the route odell beckham jr
was pushing jalen ramsey you know how
was that all going to get figured out
how is that going to get dictated
through replay and all that those are
the little things that i'm interested to
see play out in real time when you go
okay yeah maybe there was a little pass
interference by jalen ramsey as the ball
was getting close but damn odell beckham
jr did this at the 10-yard mark uh to
get open and make it like that so that's
where i want to see how they juggle that
you've just inadvertently made an
excellent point i do this from time to
time can i can i make the point before
the hard break please
we we may see an uptick in offsetting
fouls for offensive and defensive pass
interference and you just do the play
over again that may be one of the
unintended consequences
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports